あの亡くなった小何でしたっけ？東照宮
東照 東照兵さんとかね
そういう人々はまあ一応もう欲に行くわと
欲に行くと自分の社会システムは守られるとと言ってるんですね
ですから ああいう方向に行けば
中国はもう崩壊はしないんですね
それはまあ 今よく事実として見える見えるもので
そういう人々がわかっているわけじゃないんです
気がついてもないし ですから
この怒りはもうほとんど成功していない
もう破壊的であまり強烈になっちゃったらそこで名前は売れますけどね
ですから この歴史に名前が誰の残るかというと
やっぱりそういう社会
欲を強烈にあって それで行動して
何か得た人々ね 小説を書いてノーベル賞を取ったとか
もう国を治めてなんとかいいことをしましたとか
そういうのはすごい巨大な欲なんですね
でもポジティブ的な何かやっちゃいますから
そこで歴史に名前残ることになっちゃいます
すぐに歴史に名前の残るのはえらいもう犯罪者なんてなんですね
どっちかなんですね 有名になりたければ
一番早いの怒りな方なんです
片っ端からあれだこうだと壊しちゃったり
こうしたりしたら テレビやら国際的に衛星で流してくれるんです
無知の場合はそういう気持ちいいか悪いか関係なく
シャグーなんですね この漢字のシャも本当にややこしい漢字ですから
もうニュートラルフィーリングなんですね
そういうごく普通なフィーリングであって
それ理解しておきましょう
ですから なかなか自分が今無知の心かとちょっとわかりにくくなる場合もあるんです
ですから あまりこの大体簡単に言えば
やはり楽しくもないし
別に気持ち悪いでもない
なんかぼーっとしている状態ありますね
ボーっとしていると 例えば怠けている時とかね
怠けて楽しいわけじゃないし
怠けてるのにいろんなことやりたくないんだから
別に苦しいわけでもないんだけど
その時はまあ怠けっていうのはこちらに入りますから
無知に入りますから その時の感じは感覚はシャンなんですね
次の言葉はリチキッチャ
リチキッチャサンという心にリチキッチャというものが溶けちゃう
リチキッチャっていうのは日本語で疑というんですな
疑い 疑いの疑 リチキッチャ
この疑いという先手が解けちゃうんですね
心に そうすると無知というんです
そこで理解してほしいのは
このいろんな情報があって
いろんなことがあって
言ってることは疑っていますよというのは無知じゃないんです
その疑いじゃないんです
例えば ある政治家が大変素晴らしく
国のために活動しているんだよと世の中で知られているんだ
一人の人が自分に入ったいろいろ情報から考えちゃうと
なんかそうかなと疑いが生まれてくる
それは無知じゃないんです
このあんたバカではないかと
みんな言ってるんだから
それを信じればそういうことじゃない
そこの場合は理解なんです
その疑いが だから理解として出てくる疑いではないんです
僕が疑ってくださいというのは
この理解の疑いなんですね
ちゃんと情報があって
納得したらもう認めますよと
そうでなきゃ認めませんというのはもう力強いんだから
証拠を出しなさいというのは
そういう疑いじゃないんです
それはもうもっと基本的な疑いなんですね
なぜ疑いかというと 理解していないんだから
理解する能力ない 力がない
いわゆるもうボーッとしているような感じなんですね
心はしっかりしない 例えば怠け的な概念で考えちゃうと
例えばまあある人は何か言う
もう一人人は何か言う
それでもう一人誰か それ全部聞いて
どうでしょうね まあまあわからないとかね
チャレンジしない その人はわかってるか全然わかってない
よく世の中であります
例えば宗教の世界で まあ簡単にみんな言う
まあまあどんな宗教でも同じことではないか
みんないいことを言ってるんだからね
宗教はいいことを言ってますけどね
平気で簡単に楽々で言ってる人々いるんですね
ああいうのは疑いなんです
だからあなたきちんと調べたんですかと
きちんと調べて全て同じだと言ってるんですか？そうでなくて
すぐもう決めつける すぐ結論出す
はっきり知らないくせに
何でもやっぱり考え直した方がいいんです
伝統的にあるんだからとかね
みんな信じているんだからとか
日本はそうだからとかね
そこでもう自分行動する
ああいうのはもう無知
もう無知なんですね そういうことをよく我々の世界の生きてる間ではよく我々経験しているものなんです
例えば葬式に行く場合はおジュースを持っていくんですね
あれ 何の意味？なんで黒い色色着ていくんですか？なんで赤とかね
あの舞台で歌ってる時の舞台衣装とかね
ああいうもの着ていかないんですかね
で その全然理由がないんですね
葬式でっちゃったら もう大体この会社でもね
まあ葬式なんかに行かなくちゃいけないのか用意してあるんです
おジュースとか黒いネクタイとかね
これで会社で仕事で あのもうどこか葬式行かなくちゃいけない
会社で用意しているんだから
それ着て行くとかね そういうのをまあごく普通のまあ仕来りだからとかね
そこで仕来りだからやりましょうと言っているのを言うんだけど
一人の人がおジュース持ってない
それですごくあんたジュース持ってないでしょ
これいけませんと あれはもう
だからみんなジュース持っていくことには僕は何も文句言いたくないんです
で なんで持って持ってない人に対して
あんたこのピンク色のスカート履いて
ちょっと何でしょうかね
葬式なのにとかね そこはちょっとどうかなと
そこら辺でも働いてるのはもう単なる無知なんです
そこで こういうわけで
葬式にはおジュースを持っていかなくちゃいけないってきちんとした理由
訳あるならばいいんです
黒い色着なくちゃいけないんだと
白色か他のピンク色 赤や黄色着ちゃったら罰かかりますよとか
なんとかきちんとせず証拠あるならば
もう成仏できませんよとかね
そういう何もないんですね
ですから 我々はあまりこの証拠もないのに
もう信じ込んで まあそこら辺に疑い働いて
そこで証拠もないのにも
またもうわかりません
私はあまり信じませんとかね
で あの無知もたまに理屈っぽく聞こえる時もありますね
よく聞こえるのはこの僕にこの輪廻転生やらね
そういうのにものすごく頑固と反対する人々いるんですね
反対するんだけど じゃあ証拠を出せと
何一つ証拠ないんですね
輪廻がないというならば
ないというために証拠が必要なんですね
それは何もないんで そこでいろんなくだらないこと言うんですね
現代科学ではとか 現代科学っていうのは全て知ってるんですかね
現代科学もまだまだまだまだよちよち歩いてるところだけですから
知らないこといっぱいあるんで
じゃあ現代科学ではガンは解明していますかと
それぐらいのこともないのに
現代科学ではそんなことは考えられませんと
よくも平気でそういうことを言うんだから
[咳]そんなに素晴らしい現代科学
じゃあ風邪治してくれますか？それさえもできないんだから
風邪さえ治してくれる能力ない知識を持って
輪廻転生はありません
そういうのは無知もいいところなんですね
ただ 物事を深くきちんと考えたくない
それだけのことで なんか無茶苦茶無茶苦茶喋るだけ
さて 私に君は 私はもう科学的に輪廻転生あるという証拠は出せませんと
同じくないという証拠もないんだと
でもないというよりはあるんではないかという推測
疑いを晴れるぐらいの情報はあるんだとと言っちゃったら
もうあまりピンとこないんですね
僕はしっかりと証拠に基づきされてるんで
なぜならば人間持ってる知識から輪廻がこういうわけでありますよとは言えないんですね
知識の次元超えてないんだから
人間知識による方法から見れば
ないというよりはあるんではないかなと
もしかするとというぐらいの推測はできます
だから僕は相手の知識レベルの中で喋ってるのに
それさえ理解しないんですね
それで人間輪廻っていうのは私が生まれ変われますかとということなんですね
私がという実体がないんだから
ここに何かがあって そこはどこかで生まれ変わるということはないんだから
エネルギーの変換だから
ですから 例えば水の場合は完全に循環しているんですね
完全に生まれ変わっていくでしょうね
私は飲んだ水はそれで体に入って体に留まることは絶対ないんです
体を通って出て行っちゃうんです
全部 100% 出て行っていつか海に行くんです
それは分かりませんですけど
1週間の後か 1ヶ月とか 1年
2年後か分かりませんだけど
今私はもうちょっと前
この紅茶で飲んだ水がそこで
この水自体が生まれ変わるのは確実な証拠ですけど
じゃあ探してみろと 探せますかね
それは見つかりっこないんです
それには何かしらの知識というか能力が必要なんですね
海に行ったところで 海でこの水はあの
この間飲んだ紅茶の水ですよ
でもちゃんとあるんです
そんなもんで それぐらい難しいものなんですね
ですから もう信じませんよというのも無知であり
そこで同じく信じますよという人々も無知なんです
私は輪廻転生を信じますよと
あなた知ってますかと
ただの信じてるだけではないか
どっちでも無知なんです
だから僕に聞くと 僕はものすごく正しくいつでも答えますけど
最近はあまり正しい答えませんだけど
私は正しい答えっていうのは経典においてはありますと
初期経典を読んでみると
輪廻あるようにもう何のことなく書いてますよ
それは人間の正しい理解なんです
だからって私は知ってますよとか
あなたは知ってますよということではないんです
私は昔はもう質問変えてください
輪廻がありますか？じゃなくて
輪廻について釈迦様はどうおっしゃってますか？と僕に聞いてください
そうすると答えられます
あるいは輪廻について私個人がどう考えてるんですか？と聞いてください
それだったら答えます
質問変えなきゃ答えられない
輪廻ありますか？と 私はあります
で言ったっても その人何もなりませんし
ありませんで言ったって何もなりませんし
何の知識にもなりません
まあそんなもんで だからというのは
この我々の認識力がもう鈍くて
物事をしっかりと認識しない
まあなんとなく認識する
ですからそれに仏教でというものをしっかりしないという
明確じゃないという先祖が溶けてるんだと
それは無知の心だと だから瞑想中でも何かサティがしっかりしないとかね
時々あるんですね ただ言葉つけるのはなんか邪魔くさくなったとかね
じゃあぼーっとこの観察していけばいいんじゃないかなとかねと言われる
それは怠けなんですね
対象がしっかり捕まってないってことなんですね
その時は本当は無知の心が働いてるんですね
それ言われたら怒られますし
機嫌が悪くなりますから
僕はいろいろいろいろまあ
人の状態を見てね まあまあそれなりに
今までよく頑張ってきた人だったら
まあたまにそうなりますから
その時はまあその方法でもいいんですよと
ただ見てるだけでもいいんですよ
でもそうやってると眠くなるかもしれませんし
じーっと何のことなく
なんかお腹の膨らみ縮みやら体の痛みやら
なんか何となく見てると確実に眠ってしまっちゃうんです
ということは無知が働いているということなんです
本当にサマーディが強烈になって
言葉が邪魔くさくなったならば
絶対眠くはならないんです
すごい元気であるはずなんです
あまりにも見えすぎて言葉かけるのはもうかけちゃうと遅くなっちゃうんですね
あの現象の変化はもうそのまま見えてくるんだから
ものすごい早く変化していくんだから
たとえ膨らみしたっても
いろんな変化で膨らみが成り立ちますから
それは一つ一つ見えるという場合は見えすぎだから見えすぎじゃないんだけど
そうすると集中力があるんだから
もう眠気っていうのは絶対生まれないはずなんです
だから瞑想は成功するならば
もう眠気は乗り越えてるんです
眠気で悩まされている場合は
まだまだまだまだ全然進んでないってことなんです
瞑想の最初の進んでるかという最初のポイントは
瞑想すると眠くなるかならないか
体が疲れてて 座ったところでさっさと眠くなっちゃっても
すぐそれがなくなって
すぐまた目が覚めて咲いてきて動くならば
まあその人はいくらかの進んでるんです
まあそういうことで ですから
なんか瞑想してると なんかぼけーっとしてる状態とかね
なんか邪魔くさくなってるとかね
まとめてあの現象をまとめてラベリングするとかね
まとめまとめられないのに
で 心に怠けが入っちゃうと
まあ無知です 特に でも怠けっていうのは真相がないんです
あ もう時間がなくなっちゃったね
みんな逃げるんだから
早く準備した方がすごい早く私が気がつくんだけど
じゃあ終わりにします
あの儀はそういうことで
次の心は情鼓 次の心に残ってるのは情鼓なの
情鼓っていうのはもうまとめられない
もう混乱状態なんですね
もうはっきりまたそれを認識しない状態です
混乱状態 そういう 2つは無知の心で
それぐらいです じゃあ終わります
どうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございます